she was at her Mystery Schools hosting
ceremonies and initiations with teachers
from the serious star system they were
shape-shifting to reveal Humanity's full
potential to shapeshift themselves so
you know her teachings are all about our
Quantum potential and it's happening in
every initiation but she spells it out
you actually activate the bridges of
light from the edges of your DNA to the
Divine genome and the subatomic Universe
of your DNA I just had the most amazing
conversation with uh the Kashif Khan
yeah he actually had information that I
had seen that a channel and he was
saying well you know this one part about
how light works with DNA I've never seen
that in any you know book on on DNA and
I said the words you just said I've been
saying those words for 10 years Building
Bridges of light from
biological DNA to the Divine genome
within subatomic Universe of our
genetics